today designed by drew viewer thinks
he's here for some design
advice and has no idea that we actually
have a brand new room
waiting for him so let's meet chris who
went from being homeless four years ago
to now being the proud homeowner
of a four-bedroom house
check out this
hi drew my name is chris i'm 24 years
old and i live in williamstown new
jersey
i fell in hard times in 2016. i was a
freshman in college and i was working
full time and going to school full-time
and i had to pay for school out of
pocket
unfortunately when i was 18 i became
homeless and
i was living out of my car for it was
like six to eight months
it got to a point where i had literally
pennies in my account i just decided to
turn my life around i didn't like where
i was and i wanted to be in a different
place
the next day i must have applied for
over 2 000 jobs
eventually i got my first real job
selling mattresses i was still homeless
i actually was able to go back to school
and i went to an online coding academy
and i got my first engineering job and
then a
second one but i decided that i wanted
to buy a house because i wanted to have
a place for my children to grow up and
have a stable place and
a yard that's big enough for them to
play and somewhere where they can
actually call home
so i bought my house i was able to save
up enough for it
my next goal is just making my house a
home for
me and my kids i truly believe in taking
life by the horns and
manifesting your own happiness i believe
that no obstacle is too great
chris uh is here now hi
chris how are you i'm okay
thank you for having me may i ask uh
how is everything for you now uh
in your new home it's it's great you
know i'm used to
living in apartments where it's kind of
cramped and
you know maybe one bedroom maybe a few
hundred square feet or something and now
i have
this pretty decent sized house that i'm
really proud of and
i love just being able to wake up seeing
all the things that i've
built put together and that i am still
building for it so it's great
this was the first time in my life where
i was actually happy about something
that i did and i think i needed that to
help me be proud of myself and see that
what i did do was something great
what was it about this house may i ask
that spoke to you and said
this is the dream it was the perfect
foundation
i was thinking of it of what i can turn
this into and it had everything laid out
i loved
how big the yard was because i want my
kids to be able to run around and
have a place to play and you know hurt
themselves
and come to me you know and
you know have friends come over and have
barbecues have birthday parties in a
place where
they can always call home i saw the big
backyard and i was like
that's definitely something that i want
i saw the rooms that i had i saw
the basement that um i was turning into
a theater because i went to the attic
which i was turning into
a library slash art room it's the
foundation that i wanted
that said this is exactly what i need to
get started to
make it the dream house that i wanted to
be well that is so
well put and you have two beautiful
children your three-year-old son carter
and um xavier is on the way
well then uh i think there is something
important that we're gonna need to do
and i was wondering
um if you know i could uh
involve myself in your new son's room
xavier
absolutely absolutely please do okay
good so you haven't started on your
son's nursery right
right it's a blank slate thank you for
letting me be a part of this
this was your son's room as it is
now and here is what i would like to do
with it
ta-da
oh wow
which basically sweet chris i kind of
already went
and did i hope that's okay
that's completely fun with me okay
this is xavier's new nursery and you are
gonna get
every single thing that you see in here
and we were lucky enough to work with
pottery barn kids one of my
favorite stores and we just had your
baby boy
in mine and here is three
design tips um that we really got into
all right
we thought about using bins
um for shelving because you can kind of
quickly
take stuff in there throw it in there
put it back and
it'll just look really neat and tidy
also we have a toy chest here and those
really really help and this is a really
great one that doesn't allow
any like finger accidents to happen
also i did want to bring a little color
into it
um this is actually a flower home piece
of artwork
and we kind of went with like an animal
jungle theme
and the reason i chose this
crib is because i'll show you
when you bend over it there's actually a
dip
for your waist and i can't tell you how
many times i have
jabbed my ribs my xiphoid process
my solar plexus trying to get that baby
in and out
whoever figured this moment out on
behalf of every parent
and their chests thank you i so
appreciate that
all right now i like this chair
because i specifically placed it in this
area of
your room because this chair is the
power position it can see
the door that you enter because i wanted
who's ever sitting in this chair with
little xavier to feel like whoever is
coming in and out
you can be seen directly and we did
these decals on the walls
so that you could feel that fun
jungle animal motif and keep it going
with the rug and the walls but we tried
to keep it delicate
and not sort of overdo every space on
the wall
so this is it i could not say thank you
enough
you you just blew my mind and this is
probably the nicest thing somebody's
ever done to me
thumbs for me thank you so much i i
really appreciate it words can't express
my gratitude thank you chris and thank
you to carter and almost welcome to
xavier
and we'll check back in and see how
everything is going with you
you